Fünf, drei, zwei, eins, wir haben Ignition. Das Podcast-Dupo. Rässlich nach so zwei, drei Monaten irgendwas an der Verkabelung kaputt ging und eine Seite nicht mehr ging. Wo man jetzt daraus lernen könnte und sagen könnte, okay, jetzt gehe ich zu einem besseren Produkt über. Richtig. Aber ich finde gut, dass du dann treu bleibst, weil dir gefällt ja per se das Produkt, dir gefällt nur die Krabbelverarbeitung nicht. Sagen wir es so, mir gefällt das Produkt, mir gefällt nur nicht, dass das Produkt nicht funktioniert. Aber das Produkt gefällt mir. Dir gefällt die Idee des Produkts. Ja, total. Es ist alles gut. Es ist wie du ein du ein wunderschönes Auto hast, das fährt halt nicht. Aber du sagst, ich will jetzt nicht ein anderes Auto, ich will dasselbe Auto, das fährt. Und da ist der Fehler, glaube ich. Ich glaube, da ist der Fehler, genau, dass du sagst, dass du dem Auto treu bleibst. Und da war es dann auch so, dass ich mich immer entscheiden musste, will ich den Kopfhörer, der noch funktioniert, auf der rechten Seite oder auf der linken Seite, weil ich dachte mir, es ist so ein bisschen wie Tennisarm mässig, dass du dann einen Arm mega stark trainierst und den anderen gar nicht und irgendwann siehst du dann total merkwürdig aus. Wenn du morgens aufs Handy guckst, also das erste, was ich morgens mache, ist aufs Handy gucken und dann kurz bei Twitter checken Nachrichten checken. Und dann liege ich halt noch so, und mein Nachtisch ist rechts neben dem Bett. Also wache ich halt so auf und nehme das Handy mit der rechten Hand und ein Auge ist noch zu. Also das linke Auge wird noch so halb verdeckt von Kissen und so. Dann gucke ich halt also so um die fünf bis sieben Minuten, gucke ich dann auf mein Handy mit einem Auge und dann kommt es mir jeden Morgen zu dem Moment, wo ich halt dann aufstehe, richtig, und das Licht anmache und mit beiden Augen gucke und ein Auge ist doch völlig what? Was passiert hier gerade? Weil das noch gar nicht an das Licht gewöhnt. Das ist ein dummes Auge, als ob das nicht checken würde. Mein Nachbar, er arbeitet schon, nö, ich bleib noch liegen. Dann denke ich mir, redet miteinander, Kommunikation ist alles. Nein, es wird vergessen. Das ist doch diese alte Piratensache. Schlaf noch ein bisschen. Dass sie die Augenklappe hatten für ein Unterdeckauge und ein Oberdeckauge. Weil Unterdeck ist stockdunkel, weil da kannst du kein Feuer machen, weil da ist das Schießpulver. Deswegen kannst du da keine Flammen haben unter Deck. Warte, warte, ganz kurz. Und deswegen hast du als Pirat die Augenklappe. Die haben nicht ihr Auge verloren. Naja, es gibt verschiedene Theorien, das habe ich schon oft diskutiert und ich habe schon viele kluge Kommentare bekommen, die ich nicht gelesen habe. Meine Theorie ist immer noch, aber dann denke ich mir, warum machen das nur die Piraten, warum machen das nicht die normalen Seeleute, die haben ja dasselbe Problem, dass sie unterdeckt dann die Kanonenkugel holen müssen und dann überdeckt dann die Kanone, den werfen müssen. Damit herzlich willkommen zur grossen 1-2-3-Piratenfolge. Die grosse Arrrr-1-2-3-Piratenfolge.
Haben wir die 1-2-3-Piratenfolge?
Ja, tatsächlich! Piratenfolge. 1-2-3. Was sind denn Theorien zu ... Erstmal, dein Name ist Flot, hier will mein Name schon. Vielleicht, ganz kurz, kannst du danach herausschneiden. Das folgende kannst du im Schnitt beurteilend herausschneiden. Es geht los, ab jetzt! Vielleicht haben wir am Anfang ein exklusives Intro gehört, das von unserem Hörer uns zugeschickt wurde. Vielen Dank dafür, dass sie versucht, uns zu unterstützen in unserer momentanen Introarmut. Vielen Dank an den Hörer, dessen Namen ich nicht parat habe. Dennis, aber danke, dass du uns geholfen hast mit diesem interessanten Intro. Cool, ich habe es noch nicht gehört, ich habe keine Ahnung, worum es geht. Ich bin gespannt und freue mich, das zu hören. Wir kehren jetzt zurück zur normalen Folge. Piraten. Papageien, ist das eine Thing? Hatten die wirklich Papageien? Naja, ich glaube, Piraten, das ist einfach so ein bisschen ... Piraten sind die modernen Cyborgs, weil die haben so ... Okay, ich habe mein Auge verloren, Augenklappe. Hand verloren. Oh, ich habe meine Hand verloren, Haken. Haken. Ich habe meine Zunge verloren, Papache. Warum vor allem der Haken? Also was hat das für einen praktischen Nutzen, was machen die? Jetzt kann man sagen, Piraten steuern, die sind an diesem grossen Steuerbord, Haken eher nicht so sinnvoll, sie sind am Kämpfen, Haken geht so sinnvoll, warum kein Schwert als Hand? Die lassen sich so abseilen, die hängen sich wie so eine Tartanbahn. Heisst es Tartan? Ich dachte immer Tarzan, weil man wie so Tarzan sich an so einer Liane festhängt. Tartan, was ist denn? Tartanbahn. Aber ist Tartan nicht dieses rote Material, was man bei so Laufspecken hat? Tartan ist doch der türkische Sänger. Tartan Budgie. Ernsthaft, was ist Tartan? Ich dachte, es ist dieses rote Material. Du kennst dieses fluffige Material, wo man drauf läuft, das rote, was man so auf Sportplätzen hat, wo man einmal im Kreis läuft. Nein, das, ja. Und ich dachte, das heißt Tartan. Das ist Granulat. Ach, das ist Granulat. Jetzt haben wir es. Jetzt haben wir es. Aber es gibt noch andere, wie heißt es noch mal dieses rohe Fleisch, was auch so ähnlich heißt. Tata. Nicht zu verwechseln mit der Geste des Präsentierens, tada. Und dann gibt es noch ein Teta-Tet. Und Tetra-Pak. Und vis-a-vis, aber niemand weiß, was das ist. Naja. Zurück zu Piraten. Niemand spricht Französisch. Ich glaube, das ist gemacht, weil du denkst ja, jedes, was du dir an die Hand hängen könntest, hat Nachteil. Gabel, naheliegend, kannst du aber nicht ... Oh, ein Schweizer Taschenmesser wäre am besten, wo du so nach und nach das rausklappen kannst, was du wirklich gerade brauchst. Glaub ich gar nicht. Muss ich ein Segel hochspannen, nehm ich dir ein Segel hochspDing. Ich glaube, das ist wieder ein Hollywood-Ding, dass man einfach wollte, diese Geste, für die anscheinend Piraten bekannt sind, dass man sich so an der Takelage ... Come on, Alter! ... entlangsausen lässt, flitzen lässt an der Stelle, Entschuldigung, dass ich das Thema ändere. Aber kommen wir zu ... Kannst du vorher bitte einen Themenänderungsantrag stellen? Angenommen, ich hätte jetzt noch drei Gags zum zum Thema. Die werden jetzt einfach über Bord, hätte ich die hier im Waffen werfen müssen. Aber gut. Gut, möchtest du den Anker werfen und dass wir bei dem Schriftsthema bleiben? Nein, ein Themenänderungsantrag genehmigt. Alles klar. Kommen wir zu der neuen Rubrik, die ich, weil ich habe jetzt mehr Zeit, ich bin arbeitslos, deswegen möchte ich immer mehr ... Ja, du bist auch anstrengend. Du schreibst andauernd, was wollen wir besprechen, hast du dieses Essay schon gelesen, dann schreibst du noch ein paar Sachen und du denkst die Rubriken aus, bitte. Ich möchte mehr beisteuern zum Podcast-Ufo. Ich habe mir in meiner, sag ich mal, regenerativen Phase über den Jahreswechsel hinaus einige alte Folgen angehört und mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich nicht der produktive Teil des Teams bin. Ich bin, du stehst am Ruder, du ruderst und ich bin eher eher so der, der, ich muss mir kurz die Schuhe binden, und das so 20 Mal pro Stunde. Er ist über das Board gegangen, Mann über Board Manöver, und dann muss man das dauert, dann werden Leute, wir verlieren Leute, es ist alles anstrengend. Deswegen kommen wir heute zu meiner neuen Rubrik, das Wikipedia-Fundstück der Woche. Über Wikipedia müssen wir auch noch mal eine ganze Folge lang reden. Und zwar suche ich immer was raus und du liest es vor. Okay. Okay, da sag ich es. So ein Lesetest oder was ist das jetzt? Ich sass drei Wochen an dieser Rubrik. Ich sass drei Wochen an dieser Rubrik. Ich möchte die Konzeption nicht. Warum muss ich es lesen? Stefan! Ich habe mir das ausgedacht. Also bitte tu mir den Gefallen und spiel mit. So, acht. Es ist schon jetzt hier, folgendes. Bildschirmfoto 2018, eins, dreiundzwanzig, um null Uhr. Ja, guck mal, welcher ist heute? Um null Uhr wann? Guck mal, das habe ich gestern gemacht. Aber um null Uhr wann? Null Uhr neunundzwanzig, das war sogar vorgestern schon dann. Toonfish, abgeleitet von Wuvwl, Toono, ich eile, ich rase, ich schiesse entlang. Das ist mein Internetfund Stück der Woche. Das Wort Thunfisch ist abgeleitet von dem altgriechischen Wort Thuno, das heißt, ich eile, ich rase, ich schieße entlang. Das klingt vor allem wie der Anfang von einem coolen Lied. Ich schiesse entlang. Ich rase, ich reise entlang.
Ey, cool.
Vor allem, weil die ziehen ja wirklich, die sausen ja auch durchs Wasser und lassen dann ihre Eier los und fahren dann wieder flussaufwärts und sagen Tschö! Aber es ist ja unglaublich, was Altgriechisch für eine Ausdruckskraft hat. Das, was wir... Nee, im Gegenteil. Das, wofür die Griechen ein Wort hatten, Tono, dafür müssen wir umständlich sagen, ich eile, ich rase, ich schiesse entlang. Ich eile, ich rase, ich schiesse entlang. Das ist so geil, vor allem ich schiesse entlang. Also als ob in dem Verb tuno schon entlang. Also du kannst ja auch sagen, ich schiesse voran oder ich schiesse
hinzu. Aber entlang,
er sagt ja schon, dass es irgendwas Längliches ist, wo man
vorsteht, wo man links so einen
Schatten sieht, der sich vorbeischiesst.
Ja. Es ist schon, ich habe
gestern mit jemandem gesprochen,
dessen Nachname auch aus dem
Altgriechen oder sowas kommt und heißt
Nicht die Kinder, ausrufe es. Nein und heißt, nicht die Kinder ausgerechnet.
Nein, nein, das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Das ist zu lustig für die Realität.
Nein, ich weiß nicht, wie ihr Nachname war.
Ich meine, was wie Burgbichler oder so.
Und das kann man zurück, kann man sagen, das kommt daher das Wort,
das kommt daher das Wort und es heißt übersetzt nicht die Kinder.
Weil es irgendwann so einen Schießbefehl gab,
wo man nicht die Kinder umbringen sollte oder so was. Und deswegen hat jemand gesagt, geiler Name, richtig heiße. Hat jemand den Namen schon? Kann ich den Namen haben? Kann ich den Namen haben? Hey, hey, hey, hey, hör mir mal zu bitte. Kann ich das als Nachnamen haben? Ja, komm, halt, ha Hau ab jetzt! Alles klar, Thomas Gurtbichler, Instagram ändern! Alle hatten Scheißtag, alle hatten Scheißtag, ich hab einen neuen Namen, yo! Wie das damals war, als man sich Namen gesucht hat, oder zum Beispiel Volvo, wo unser Lateinlehrer gefragt hat, als wir gesagt haben, als wir mal wieder rebelliert haben und die Stühle in die Tafel geworfen haben, gesagt haben, wir brauchen nie Latein, hat er gesagt,
Arete,
was, ihr kennt doch zum Beispiel die
Autofirma Volvo.
Und dann die alle so still geworden,
so, ja, stimmt, er hat recht,
er hat relatable, er hat etwas gesagt,
das wir schon wissen, boah, krass.
Leute, die französisch gewählt haben, diese Loops,
die wissen nicht, was Volvo bedeutet.
Alter, stimmt, ja, Volvo, und er so, naja, aber wisst ihr auch, was Volvo heißt?
Boah, nee, krass, Alter, stimmt, er hat recht, er hat uns jetzt am Haar.
Ohne Scheiße, er hat vielleicht recht.
Und er sagte, Volvo heißt, ich walze alles nieder.
Ja.
Und das ist, wo ich mir dachte, ich walze alles nieder.
Wo ist das alles drin, wo ist das Niederwalzen her?
Ich Rolle heisst doch nur, Volvo.
Ja, aber er hat es damals gesagt, als ich walze alles nieder.
War es eine Kritik an der Automobilindustrie?
Audi? Audi heißt?
Ich horch, horch, ja genau.
Horch!
Ja, der Imperativ.
Mensch, wie gebildet man, ey.
Geil!
Latein, ey.
Latein ist die ultimative, ist nicht nur, es geht nicht nur darum, wie man spricht, es geht
auch darum, was man, wie viel Aufwand man betreiben muss. Also Beispiel, Salve heißt Hallo, du. Salvete heißt ihr. Es ist also, deren Form von Hallo unterscheidet schon zwischen Mehrzahl und Singular. Und dann auch noch dieses Bravo, Brava-Nummer. Also du musst mit einer Frau anders reden als mit einem Mann. Du musst so viel Aufwand betreiben, um ein Wort zu sagen. Das ist mein Argument. Aber stimmt, das gibt es im Deutschen nicht. Das gibt es im Deutschen nicht. Nein. Hallo ihr, man sagt Hallo ihr. Hallo du. Hallo Leute, würde man sagen. Hallo da. Also, Salvete ist gleich Hallo Leute. Ey, man muss sich schon bei den einfachsten Dingen Gedanken machen. Ich glaube, wenn du im Lateinland warst oder halt zum Bäcker gegangen bist, er würde wie ich sein und mir vorher sich überlegen, was man gleich sagt, wenn man drankommt. Das macht doch jeder von uns, oder? Jeder geht doch morgen zum Bäcker und überlegt sich schon in der Reihe, wenn du der Dritte bist in der Reihe, überlegt sich schon, ich sag bestimmt den Satz, ich hätte gerne ein Laugenbrötchen und ein belegtes Gouda-Brötchen. Den gehe ich so oft durch in meinem Kopf, dass er perfekt kommen muss. Vor allem das Krasse ist ja, es gibt ja nicht nur Latein, es gibt ja noch das Latein des Lateins, Altgriechisch. Also wer denkt, Latein ist krass? No, und das mag ich an der Realität, das mag ich an der echten Welt, dass es immer noch einen Step höher gibt. So, keine Ahnung, du spielst ein Videogame. Seitdem du die echte Welt entweckst hast, bist du ein anderer Mensch. Du spielst ein Videogame, sagen wir es mal, ein Videoplay und du zockst das, du daddelst das. Ein First-Person-Shooter. Und dann bist du meinetwegen Master Chief, ja, Master Chief. Relatable. Und dann frisst du den Pilz und dann bist du der Ultra-Master Chief. Aber das war's dann auch. Da geht's dann nicht höher. Wohingegen in der echten Welt hast du immer noch was Krasseres. Und dann denkst du, Altgriechisch und da gibt es noch Sanskrit. Und das große Latinum. Vor allem, wenn du in dem Zeitalter von Latein gelebt hast und das große Latinum nicht bestanden hast, dann warst du ein Vollidiot. Ja, das stimmt. Hast du noch ein großes Latinum? Nein, ich habe gar kein Latinum. Oh, guck mal, ich habe das Latinum. Ich war der einzige in der Klasse, der kein ... Es hat gereicht, Latein mit einer vier oder besser abzulegen. Wer war der einzige in der Klasse, der etwas schlechteres als eine vier hatte? Bingo! Florentinus, der Blühende ... Der blühende ... Der Trottel. Stefan ist ja Grieche, Stefan ist griechisch und heißt ... der lustigste Mensch der Welt. Ach, das passt ja. Spanisch hatte ich auch, ich hatte spanische Latein und englische als Fremdsprache. Und ich habe mal, das ist mir noch nicht so eingefallen, in so einem komischen Tagtraum, wo ich mir dachte, das war tatsächlich meine Realität. Ich konnte mal fliessend spanische Texte schreiben. Wirklich? Ja. Aber auch komplexe. Ich konnte komplexe Gedichtsanalysen schreiben, ich konnte sagen, dieser Junge springt da gerade
in den Pool auf diesem seltsamen Wimmelbild, was wir gerade beschreiben müssen, und so weiter.
Ich konnte wirklich zwei Seiten Texte schreiben in Spanisch und ich habe keine Ahnung, was alle
Wörter bedeuten jetzt mehr. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich kann sagen, ich kann Ola sagen, aber dann
bei Buenas Tades weiß ich schon nicht mehr, sagt man jetzt Bueno oder Bene, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich kann sagen, ich kann Ola sagen, aber dann bei Buenas Tades weiß ich schon nicht mehr, sagt man jetzt Bueno oder Bene, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich kann nichts mehr sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich bin verloren im Spanischen, aber ich habe mal Text gesprochen, wo man sich auch fragt, da muss doch was falsch laufen im Schulsystem. Ich glaube aber, dass du es relativ einfach wieder neu lernen kannst. Ich glaube, wenn du es mal konntest, dann brauchst du wesentlich weniger Zeit, um das wieder zu reaktivieren. Also ich glaube, wenn du dich jetzt hinsetzen würdest, ich glaube, das Gehirn ist da schon clever, das sagt so, oh, das brauchen wir jetzt gerade nicht, das stebe ich halt in den Schrank, so wie halt die alten... Oder man muss vielleicht so Assoziationen bilden, also man muss vielleicht ein Sangria riechen oder sowas, oder so ein Sombrero aufsetzen. Man muss so ein paar Assoziationen wecken. Wir hatten ja damals eine Französischlehrerin, die sehr darauf erpicht war, dass wir nicht nur irgendwie Grammatik lernen oder dann Vokabeln, sondern dass wir sprechen können, dass wir frei sprechen können. Und das heißt, sie hat uns relativ früh schon dazu motiviert, frei zu sprechen, ohne dass wir irgendeinen Wortschatz haben oder irgendwelche Grammatik kennen. Aber sie hat, und dann gab es mal zwei Arten von Schülern, die, die halt schüchtern waren und die dann wirklich nur die Worte gesagt haben, wo sie sich hundertprozentig sicher waren. Und die, die rum bullshitten und nervig sind. Und die, wo ich dazugehört habe, einfach kompletten Nonsens reden. Und dann oft die Frage, was seht ihr auf diesem Bild, einfach Oui, je peux dire, comment des fonds, très magnifique, le paquet des tribons, le fromage à Paris. Und ich habe noch wirklich vor meinen Augen in höchster Auflösung das Gesicht der Lehrerin, die wirklich hoch angestrengt mit zu einemieß denn nochmal diese französische Schlageserien, dieses Der Computer? Nummer zwei, wirft dich den richtigen Freund. Auch ein geiles Video. Guckt euch mal, gibt es Nummer drei. France Gall. France Gall, sie kommt in einer deutschen Show, Alter, sie kommt in einer deutschen Show heraus, eine Big Band spielt diesen catchy Song, es ist eine unfassbare Stimmung, was ein geiler Song, catchy, die eine Live Band spielt und man hat immer diese Zwischenschnitte ins Publikum, wo Deutsche sitzen, die in Anzug, in Abendgarderobe. Ist das eine andere Sendung, die die dazwischen geschnitten haben, wo die andere Publikumschnitte benutzt haben, weil entweder, die sitzen alle auf so einer Beerdigungsstimmung, alle gucken so runtergezogen, die haben gar keinen Bock auf gar nichts mehr, schon gar nicht auf Franz Gall, die da eine gute Zeit hat und einen guten Song performt. Ja, sucht mal auf YouTube Franz Gall und dann Computer und dann gibt es eine große, das erste Video findet, und ich finde, die hat echt Ausstrahlung, die hat so ein junges, viriles Ding, das da singt. Ja, ich find aber auch so ein bisschen, das sind Schritte, die sie macht. Sie ist total steif, aber sie ist wesentlich steifer und holziger, als es heute Popstars sind, die perfekt tanzen können. Aber ich finde, dadurch hat das irgendwo was Natürliches, was offensichtlich ist. Aber es ist tatsächlich schwer, Konzerte wahrnehmen, ist ein interessantes Thema. Vor kurzem war zum Beispiel Rocket Beans Geburtstag, Gebohnstag in Hamburg im grossen Gloria-Theater. Und alle saßen und die Bühne war vorne, natürlich man sitzt auf einem Stuhl. Die Bühnen sind vorne. Und dann gab es den Balkon, links nach oben. Also der Zuschauer, der auf die Bühne schaut, muss nach links oben schauen. Und da war die Band. Und dann gab es immer zwischen Umbaupausen oder so hat die Band gespielt, das heißt alle saßen auf ihrem Spielstuhl und haben nach links oben und plötzlich schnellen alle Köpfe so nach links oben so als hätte jemand laut geknallt und oben war die Band plötzlich und dann, also die Band die ja durchaus, sag ich mal, auch Hip-Hop, Rap also im Bereich der, sag ich mal Sprechmusik und der Rhythmusmusik sich bewegt, also auch wirklich treibende Beats. Du bist ja um Jahre gealtert, als tatsächlich in den letzten Wochen präsentiert hat. Treibende Rhythmen. Da war es schon schwer fürs Publikum, das adäquat aufzunehmen, weil natürlich möchte man schunkeln, man möchte wippen. Aber man sitzt halt auch in englischen ... Man sitzt halt und man guckt nach links oben,
was die tanzeunfreundlichste Pose ist, die man überhaupt haben kann.
War ein tolles Event, das Publikum war super drauf, alles geil.
Aber ich hab das gesehen und dachte mir,
ihr macht dem Publikum nicht leicht, eine gute Zeit zu haben.
Man kennt ja auch in den Theaterstücken von Schulen meistens,
oder schlechten Theaterstücken, gibt's ja immer diese Idee,
man lässt jetzt mal Leute aus dem Publikum kommen.
Das ist ja immer das, aus dem Publikum aufstehen. In so Theaterstücken, wo In Theaterstücken, wo dann immer aus dem Publikum Gängen Leute auf die Bühne gehen. Du meinst Schauspieler, die im Publikum sitzen. Schauspieler, die im Publikum sitzen oder durch den Hintereingang auf die Bühne gehen und dann im Gang man das Szenen spielen oder so. Denn wir müssen ja die Grenzen der Bühnen aufsprengen. Und deswegen, und es gibt immer, also man muss sagen, gut 90% des Publikums drehen sich dann um, um da hinzugucken. Aber es gibt so zehn Prozent, die sagen, no way, wo die Köpfe knallhart nach vorne gucken, auf die Bühne, wo nichts passiert. Licht ist doch aus, Licht ist aus. Es passiert nichts an der Bühne, der Vorhang ist zu. Weil es hat durchaus einen Grund, dass die Bühne erhöht gebaut ist, sodass sie nicht nur die erste Reihe was sehen kann, was aber bei Gangstücken
nicht der Fall ist. Und ich kann gut nachvollziehen,
dass Herbert, der sich umdreht
und einfach drei Sekunden lang merkt,
ich sehe gar nichts, einfach sich denkt,
nope, ich sitze nach vorne.
Aber es hat auch was, also ich finde, man muss wenigstens versuchen
hinzugucken, weil immer diese,
wenn man dann diese oft ja dann grauen Schöpfe
sieht, die einfach nach vorne gucken, die einfach keinen Scheiss geben, die keinen Bock haben, das zu sehen. Die sagen, nö, ich guck da hin. Da soll das passieren. Herrlich, herrlich. Und es gibt auch immer die zwei, drei armen Schlucker, die am Gang direkt neben den Schauspielern stehen, die den Spot einfach komplett in die Fresse geballert bekommen, so keine Rücksicht auf dem Kunden. Den auch viele aus dem Publikum mit angucken, weil er auch Teil des Spots ist. Die Definition von Kollateralschaden. Wir wollen die Schauspieler sehen, aber Tante Erna und die kleine Trixie, die mitgekommen ist, die kleine Cousine, kriegt einfach ihre Netzhaut weggebrannt. Weggebrannt. Von dem Spot. Aber sie will natürlich auch die Stimmung, die lustre Stimmung des Stückes mitnehmen und grinst zu halb und die Augen zu und man weiß nicht genau. Ach Gott, das ist schon unangenehm. Tatsächlich, früher im Mittelalter in Tagebucheinträgen hat man restaurierte Tagebucheinträgen von Leuten, weil man wollte wissen, wie war Shakespeare, wie wurde das damals aufgeführt. Wer waren die Leute, die Shakespeare waren? Was waren das für Leute? Gibt es die Theorie, dass es die Queen war? Naja, Shakespeare was an Inside-Job. Sehr gut. Tagebuchanträge von Leuten, die sich Stücke angeschaut haben. Und damals hat man geschrieben, nicht I saw a play, sondern I heard a play. Also die Leute haben hingeschrieben, yesterday I heard a play of Shakespeare. Das waren so die ersten Twitter-Kommentare, die sarkastischen Twitter-Kommentare. Hashtag, oh, baut mal die Bühne ein bisschen, damit man besser sehen kann. Vielleicht, und man weiß nicht, entweder war es einfach ein anderer Sprachgebrauch, zu sagen, oder sie haben einfach nichts gesehen. Oder es könnte durchaus ein sarkastischer ... Yesterday I smelled the people. I smelled a lovely play. Sehr gut, aber man weiß es nicht. Ist das Sarkasmus? Das geht notwendigerweise verloren. Es geht unter. Ohne Scheiß, interessanter Gedanke. Das, was wir gerade machen, Comedy geht unter. Comedy ist immer im Zeitgeist zu verstehen. Damals, wenn die Gags gemacht hätten, keine Ahnung, verstehen wir nicht. Wir nehmen gerade alles ernst, was sie schreiben, in dem Tagebuch eintragen. Und in 100 Jahren nehmen die alles ernst, was wir gerade sagen. Woher willst du das denn wissen? Also es könnte ja tatsächlich, und ich meine, der hat sich Stücke von Shakespeare angeschaut, der hatte durchaus Wit. Da war Wit vorhanden. Da war Wit vorhanden. Das kommt ja nicht von irgendwo her. Wit. Wit. Wip. Und deswegen weiß man nicht, aber man ging da vor, also entweder war der Fokus anders, dass die gesprochene Sprache im Vordergrund steht und wenn man, dass man, heute liest man die Theaterstücke ja oft, dass es viel verloren geht und das gesprochene Wort, das ist, das hört natürlich angebracht, weil die reden ja auch primär, da passiert ja nicht so viel visuell. Das stimmt. Von daher ist es durch das angebracht zu sagen, hört, oder man sagt einfach, ja die haben einfach nichts gesehen. Ja, man weiß es nicht mehr genau. Finde ich interessant. Ich habe auch einen Rubrik, einen Rubrikvorschlag gerade. Wow, ich finde es toll, dass du mitziehst, dass der neue Aktivist man 2018 auf dich überschwappt. Ich nenne die Rubrik Late to the Party. Late to the Party. Finde ich gut. Wir sind nicht tagesaktuell, finde ich auch gut. Wir sind ein zeitloser Podcast. Und manchmal, wenn wir tagesaktuell sind, sind wir meistens ein bisschen zu spät. Und genauso in dem Fall. Siehe die vorangegangene Diskussion über Shakespeare. Osama Bin Laden. Es ist schon ein bisschen her, das Thema. Und ich kann es nicht fassen, dass wir das damals nicht mitbekommen haben. Aber er wurde umgebracht und vor ein paar Monaten wurden die Rechner ja auch konfisziert, die er hatte. Er hat ja da gewohnt, lange Zeit, da wo er dann getötet wurde. Wo sich, weiß ich gar nicht mehr genau, wo, soll der erarbeitet oder sowas, weiß ich nicht genau. Er wurde dann, warum grinst du so? Weißt du das? Gar nicht, glaube ich, er, oder? Weiß nicht, keine Ahnung. Er wurde umgebracht und hat dann seinen Rechner konfistiert und so, und jetzt vor ein paar Monaten wurde bekannt gegeben, was auf seinem Rechner alles so war. Worms, 3D. Ganz kurz, ich muss kurz sagen, also, Animal Crossing, Spiel Animal Crossing, sehr viel Anime, wirklich sehr viel Anime, der Film Ice Age, der Film Cars, der Film Chicken Little, Sean Das Schaf und er hat viele YouTube-Videos runtergeladen. runtergeladen. Also, man muss den Kopf behalten kurz, dass Osama Bin Laden
hingegangen ist auf YouTube,
den YouTube-Downloados runtergeladen. Also, man muss sich im Kopf behalten, kurz, dass
Osama Bin Laden hingegangen ist auf YouTube,
den YouTube-Downloader aufgerufen hat,
um diese Videos, die Osama Bin Laden
so toll fand, runterzuladen.
Für diese Videos wurden sehr viel Aufwand betrieben,
um sie im Internet freien Raum zu gucken.
Mr. Bean,
Charlie bit my finger.
Klassiker.
Den muss man gesehen haben.
Und Amazing Animated Optical Illusions.
Wie konnten wir das nicht wissen?
Chicken Little, Cars ist ein guter Film.
Cars ist ein guter Film.
Cars ist kein guter Film.
Ich finde, es ist ein guter Film.
Wo ist Up?
Wo ist Toy Story? Wo sind die richtig guten Filme? Charlie Bitt My Finger, die Vorstellung, dass er Charlie Bitt My Finger gesehen hat und nicht mehr konnte von oben, diese kleine amerikanische Familie. Wo ich vor allem dachte, das finde ich nicht nur jetzt lustig, lad das mal runter. Das finde ich in zwei Wochen auch noch lustig. Hey, Mohammed, lad mir das mal kurz runter. Aber die Vorstellung, dass der Charlie-Bin-My-Finger so lustig findet und genauso wie wir, versteht und und und und ja oder halt ganz anders, er nimmt das halt als die Degeneration des westlichen Menschen. Aber das guckt man sich dann so oft an, ich weiß es nicht, aber hat der Kinder denn? Ja, ich glaube schon und offensichtlich Animal Crossing. Ich meine, hey, hey, hey. Ja, ich finde auch Animal Crossing gut. Sorry, nichts gegen Animal Crossing. Ist ein gutes Spiel. Ich finde auch Carson, ich finde auch Ice-Edge einen guten Film. Schon das scharf. Was würdest du sagen, wenn man jetzt deinen Laptop konfiszieren würde, wie gut beschreibt der Inhalt deines Laptops deine Persönlichkeit? Wenn du jetzt tot bist und man sagt, ah, Laptop, guckst du dich den an, würdest du sagen, das ist ein adäquaterer Spiegel deiner Persönlichkeit? Ich glaube, es ist ein adäquaterer Spiegel meiner Wirklichkeit als meine Wirklichkeit.
Nach außen hast du ja immer noch die Wahl, wie willst du sein?
In einem intimen Raum wie dem Desktop zum Beispiel, allein der Desktop, wie das aufgebaut ist, bei dir sind ja, muss man sagen, 50 Ordner, verschiedene, viele heißen gleich, auch und so weiter, viele Dateien mit Nummern hinten dran, dass man schon weiss, okay, da ist was schiefgegangen und so weiter. Und bei mir ist es schon ein bisschen aufgeräumter, auch ein bisschen Chaos, viele Ideendokumente und so. Ja, du hast Ideen oder was. Viele Bilder, wo ich mit Pokal und Medaillen bei Sportveranstaltungen stehe.
Dieser subtile Unterschied, ich habe Dokumente, Stefan hat Ideen-Dokumente.
Viele Final Draft, Drehbuchdateien, okay, ein bisschen angefangen, ein paar zu Ende gemacht und so weiter.
Und ich meine, ich glaube, im intimen Raum des Desktops und des Browser-Verlaufs vor allem,
glaube ich, spielt schon gut die Wirklichkeit wieder, die wahre Persönlichkeit.
Ja, absolut. Aber ich lade auch YouTube-Videos runter, weil ich fahre viel mit dem Zug und da kann man sich oft auf das WLAN nicht verlassen und oft haben die gar keinen WLAN. Deswegen lade ich auch viel runter und das macht tatsächlich großen Spaß. Da habe ich große Freude daran, das immer zu sammeln, zu gucken, worauf hätte ich Lust jetzt in vier Stunden, lad mir das alles runter und ich schaue vieles davon dann auch tatsächlich an. Ich habe, also kurz behind Podcast-Ufo, wir haben nicht so viel zu tun gehabt in dem Jahreswechsel. Wir haben eigentlich, wir haben mal voneinander gelassen. Wir haben mal, also wir haben nicht viel voneinander gehört, eigentlich gar nichts. Wir haben wirklich uns verabschiedet zu Weihnachten, zu Neujahr und jetzt haben wir uns vor einer Woche wiedergesehen zum ersten Mal. Und inzwischen war Funkstelle. Man muss da auchil. Wir verbringen sehr viel Zeit, das ganze letzte Jahr haben wir aufeinander gehockt, wirklich fast fünf Tage die Woche, 24 Stunden hart anstrengend. Und haben dann noch Podcast-Rufungs und andere Projekte nebenbei gemacht. Und tatsächlich war es mal ganz gut, so ein bisschen voneinander zu lassen. Und dann fand ich es aber ganz toll, weil zwischendurch habe ich ein Lebenszeichen von dem bekommen. Ich wusste auch nicht, ist er noch am Leben? Was machst du jetzt? Kommst du mit einem grossen Bart wieder, hast den Mount Everest bestiegen, du hättest alles machen können. Das ist wie so dieses typische Summer Break in Amerika, wo man danach, wenn ein neuer Mensch wiederkommt. Und ich wusste nicht, hat er sich verändert. Und dann kam plötzlich die Nachricht, irgendwann, so es war, Anfang Januar rum, kam dann so um 14 Uhr die Nachricht, Florentin Will benutzt jetzt Telegram. Und ich habe es gesehen und dachte mir so, hm, good for him. So, das war schön. Ja, wie so ein Elternteil, das sagt so, hey, aus dem wird noch mal was. Ja, ich dachte mir so, okay. Der ist nicht ganz verloren. Nee, vor allem auch, weil es eine Kommunikations-App ist. Ich finde gut, du gehst raus, du gibst dich selbst nach draußen und schreibst mit Leuten und kommunizierst mit der Welt, fand ich toll einfach.
Tatsächlich heute ein alter Schulfreund von mir hat sich auf Telegram angemeldet und man kriegt dann diese Nachricht.
Und dann denkt man sich, oh Mist, als ich mich angemeldet habe, haben auch alle diese Nachricht bekommen und dann fühlt man sich wie in so einer Schlangengrube, wo einen plötzlich alle angucken und so, ah, was macht er jetzt, schreibt er mir jetzt, schreibt er mir jetzt, warum schreibt er mir nicht? Ich kenne ihn gut, ich will ihm schreiben, warum schreibt er mir nicht? Soll ich ihm schreiben? Und dann ist man schon wieder in diesem Stand-off drin, wo man nicht weiß, was los ist. Schön, weil es auch so eine Uhrzeit war, wo man sich denkt, wo man sich vorstellt. Ich wusste ja, dass du arbeitslos bist und nichts zu tun hast und da zu Hause auf deiner Couch sitzt wahrscheinlich und betrunken oder keine Ahnung, aber dass du dann einfach da so sitzt und dann plötzlich auf die Idee kommst, das für eine gute Idee zu halten, die Telegram runterzuladen und das einzurichten, fand ich toll einfach. Warum gab es eine Hintergrundstory? Ich bin total kommunikativ, ich will einfach alle, ich will alle Schleusen öffnen. Ja, genau, ähnlich. Naja, ich sag mal, wenn man auf den althergebrachten Kommunikationsplattformen vielleicht nicht mehr so viel, nicht so mehr so viele Nachrichten bekommt, nicht mehr so viel, hey, der letzte Sketch war super, sondern vielleicht eher nicht so viel Kontakt,
dann sagt man, hey, dann gucken wir mal, was die bei Telegram machen.
Ist doch ... Was ist das USP von Telegram noch?
Früher war es doch, dass die super verschlüsselt war.
Genau, aber mittlerweile ist WhatsApp auch verschlüsselt.
Also, noch mal zur Frage, warum hast du die Telegram?
Die haben gute Sticker. Die haben immer diese Sticker.
Oder nicht?
Tolle Gives, auch Simpsons-Sticker zum Beispiel. Hitler-Sticker, viele Hitler-Sticker. Hitler-Sticker, alles. Ganz toll, Freddie Mercury. Du hast die Freddie Mercury? Nee, es gibt einen Sticker. Ich hab mich schon relativ früh auf Sticker festgelegt. Weil ich find's dann immer gut, wenn man das durchzieht. So, und ich hab mich leider auch, glaub ich, auf die Falschen festgelegt. Und zwar, da gibt's ja so ein paar vorinstallierte, dann, glaube ich, die anderen muss man sich irgendwie kaufen oder irgendwie tauschen miteinander. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Aber, naja, da ist eine ganze Welt dahinter. Wenn du vor allem mit dem Finger kurz abrutschst, bist du in einer ganz anderen Stickerwelt, wo du denkst, wow, wow, wow, wow, okay, okay. Und dann machst du langsam, legst du das Handy weg und warte, bis es in den Standby-Modus geht, weil du plötzlich in einem, du kommst ja nicht mehr raus. Du schaust keinem Sticker in die Augen, du weißt nicht, was jetzt passiert. Nee, auch so Katzen, wo man denkt, okay, alles klar, genug gesehen. Ja, ja. Ich habe mich für den Fuchsmillionär entschieden und ich glaube, es war eine schlechte Entscheidung. Es wirkte auf den ersten Blick so, ah, Fuchs, woher hat er das ganze Geld her, dachte ich mir so, krass, ist ein Vorbild für mich, dieser Fuchs. Fuchsmillionär. Weil. Ich meine, ein Menschen-Millionär ist schon mal beeindruckend.
Wow, der hat was geleistet.
Aber als Fuchs so viel Geld.
Das war was Illegales im Spiel.
Der Spähfuchs muss zwei Jobs schieben.
Der Schwäbe-Schallfuchs und der Spähfuchs ist derselbe.
Ville Füchse in der Medienwelt.
Der hat zwei Jobs.
Der kommt nicht mal mit einem Job in die Runden.
Währendgegen der andere Fuchs ist Millionär.
Peter Fox.
Aber Fuchs.
Fuchs. Habe ich letztens gesuchtucht, hatte ich nur Ohrwurm nach Es ist wesentlich komplexer und harmonisch interessanter als das, was wir gerade machen, aber es ist schon ein tolles Album. Ja, und ich wusste nicht, was es ist, und das Problem ist, wenn man Zeit hat, je mehr Zeit man hat, desto mehr Zeit verschwendet man notgedrungen. Weil wenn du gerade irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Notarzt auf dem Weg zum, keine Ahnung, Leitplanke ist durch Brustkorb gebohrt und du hast einen Ohrwurm, denkst du dich, jetzt nicht wichtig. Aber wenn du zu Hause sitzt und jetzt, dann denkst du, ich könnte jetzt auch einfach die nächsten 13 Stunden als Lebens damit verschwenden, nach diesem Song zu suchen. Und dann tust du es und dann denkst du dir einfach, gut, der Tag ist vorbei, gute Nacht, die Sonne ist unten und ich gehe ins Bett und ich sehe, ich habe halt nichts erreicht. Ich habe, wenn ich so eine Musikphase gehabt habe über Weihnachten, neuer, und ich habe einen ganz tollen YouTube-Channel entdeckt. YouTube-Empfehlung der Woche! Sehr, sehr gut. Adam Neely. Ja, dem folge ich auch, der ist richtig gut. Er ist ein New Yorker Musiker, der zum einen Vlogs macht über seine New Yorker Musikszene.
Ganz interessant. Ja, den folge ich auch, der ist gut. Ist ein New Yorker Musiker, der zum einen Vlogs macht über seine New Yorker Musikszene und ganz interessant, wie er da rumtourt und cool aufdrückt hat, der vor allem auch in einer Weddingband ist.
Er ist ein unglaublich begabter Jazzmusiker, hat auch einen Master oder keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall doppelter Abschluss in Musik und Komposition.
Einer der besten Bassisten, die ich jemals gesehen habe und spielt auch auf Wedding in Wedding-Bands halt einfach normale Bruno Mars-Songs und so und begleitet das halt und ist einfach ein unglaublich guter Musiktheoretiker. Und der gibt sich immer richtig Mühe und macht ganz toll aufbereitete Musikvideos, unter anderem zu solchen Themen wie, was sind überhaupt Töne, die wir wahrnehmen als Töne. Und in Wahrheit sind Töne auch nur Rhythmen. Denn wenn du das, was ich gerade mache, auf dem Tisch schaust, ein regelmäßiges Boom, Boom, Boom, wenn das beschleunigt wird, wird es zum Ton. Und wenn in einer Zeit mehr Töne gemacht werden, mehr Bums gemacht werden, ist die Herzzahl halt größer und deswegen wird es ein anderer Ton. Also Töne sind ja auch nur beschleunigte Rhythmen. Das ist auch ein ganz, ganz interessanter Gedanken hat der und die führt er immer ganz toll aus und das sind wirklich auf jeden Fall Abonnieren und es macht Spaß. Und auch viel so Sachen wie Tonarten, ich glaube, das ist so ein Ding, also wo, also wenn man muss schon Musiknerd sein. Naja, wenn man Musik selber ein Musikinstrument gelernt hat, dann hat man grob eine Ahnung, was eine Tonart ist, aber viele, das sind glaube ich Dinge, die Leute, die keine Ahnung von Musik haben, gerne benutzen, so Dur und Moll, aber nicht den Ansatz einer Ahnung haben, was das überhaupt bedeutet. Er hat sich die Frage gestellt, was ist die traurigste Tonart? Weil tatsächlich fällt es auf, dass Leute, die besonders traurig schreiben wollten, die zum Beispiel Todesmärsche geschrieben haben, häufig, glaube ich, in S-Moll geschrieben haben. Und da hat man sich halt endlich gefragt, warum ist das ein traurigerer Tonrat als alle anderen Tonratten? Und dann kommt er zum Beispiel auf so Themen, dass damals Klaviere anders gestimmt waren. Und zum Beispiel deswegen, daran kann es liegen und so. Deswegen hat man auch oft seine anderen Tonratten komponiert und so weiter. Also, wenn man sich ein bisschen für Musik interessiert, macht es unglaublich Spaß, diesem Typ zu folgen. Total spannend und fällt genau in ein Thema rein, über das ich gerade nachdenke, weil je mehr Zeit, ich habe viel Zeit gerade, und je mehr Zeit man hat, je mehr Zeit man hat, desto mehr überlegt man sich, was soll mit seiner Zeit anfangen. Und erst mal, wenn du einfach mal losgelassen wirst in Ferien, zwei Wochen, dann verplemperst du erst mal Zeit, bist den ganzen Tag am Computer. Und irgendwann kommt der Punkt, wo du denkst, hm, ich muss jetzt langsam überlegen, ob ich die Zeit nicht besser nutzen kann. Und das Erste, was einem, glaube ich, einem modernen Menschen heute einfällt, ist weniger Internet. Zu sagen, mal auch mal Bücher lesen, mal rausgehen. Das Erste ist bei mir, kürzer schlafen. Echt? Ja, eher aufstehen. Ach so, ja, na gut, das auch, aber vielleicht dann einfach zu sagen, okay, aber dann überlegt man sich, na ja gut, warum eigentlich? Und dann bin ich bis zwischen zwei Polen gefangen, entweder weniger Internet benutzen, aka mal ins Museum gehen, mal ins Theater gehen, mal ins Kino gehen oder Internetzeit besser nutzen. Zum Beispiel, man klickt sich ja durch YouTube den halben Tag. Was kann man auf YouTube anschauen, was immer noch Spaß macht, aber die Zeit besser nutzt, wo man auch was lernt? Und ich meine, da gibt es viele Sachen, ich schaue mir stundenlang Dota-Videos an, die zehn besten Dota-Kills und so, da lernst du gar nichts. Zehn besten Jobs, das ist interessant. Ja, Arbeitsamt.de bin ich auch oft unterwegs. Aber viele Sachen, und da möchte ich ein paar Sachen empfehlen. Oh, ich habe da in der Hinsicht auch, man kann kostenlos die, wie gesagt, Musik war ein großes Thema bei mir, ich habe die Yale Music Music Classes gemacht von der Yale University. Kann man einfach kostenlos, kann man sich da die Musik, glaube ich, Komposition ist, glaube ich, das Fach, tatsächlich kann man machen, das ist toll. Und man denkt jetzt sofort irgendwie an TED-Talks oder an irgendwie Vorlesungen. Aber es gibt ja auch gerade, finde ich ... Sorry, ich habe sofort daran gedacht. Es gibt ja in dem Unterhaltungsbereich, wie Videosp oder Popkultur auch Kanäle, die sich dann irgendwie, jeder kennt, Nerdwriter oder so, wo man sich auch mit so Video-Essays dann so irgendwie mit den Themen, die man eh schon kennt, irgendwie intellektuell auseinandersetzt und das irgendwie interessant ist. Und was zum Beispiel für Videospiele möchte ich empfehlen, Mark Brown macht sehr gute Videos zu Videospielen über Game Design, was dahinter steckt, wie verschiedene Spiele verschiedene Konzepte nutzen, was super interessant ist, was gerade auch für Pen and Paper und sowas, wo ich mich mit beschäftige, total interessant ist, wie geht man Methoden um in Videospielen, wenn jemand stirbt, was passiert dann, da gibt es ganz viele verschiedene Arten, wie verschiedene Spiele das machen, oder wie sind Dungeons Design und so, also Mark Brown, ganz sehr simpel. Wenn man hier auf A drückt, dann kommt man über das Hindernis besser. Also wenn man hier Doppel A macht, dann also sowas vielleicht. Sehr gut, Mark mit K, Mark Brown und ich glaube, ein Favorit von uns beiden, auch Jenny Nicholson, können wir mal empfehlen. Jenny Nicholson! Jenny Nicholson! Eine, bin ich vielleicht sogar die beste Bloggerin, wenn es um Star Wars, Popkultur, Video-Filmkritik geht. Die ist super.
Und die hat jetzt sogar auch eine Webserie gestartet.
Wirklich?
Über so Cosplayer.
Ich weiß aber gerade nicht genau, wie die heißt.
Aber die findet ihr schon, wenn ihr sucht Jenny Nicholson.
Die ist lustig, die hat einen super Humor.
Sie liest auch manchmal so Fanfiction vor.
Die hat eine ganz seltsame Pläne, die sich immer vornimmt und die begleitet.
Und die hat einen ganz speziellen Humor, der einfach Spaß macht, den zu erkunden. Die hat supergeilen Content, die redet über Filme, über Bücher. Es gibt ein extrem lustiges Video, wo sie Halloween-Kostüme anprobiert und vor allem so Halloween-Kostüme, die niemand kauft, die immer übrig bleiben. Und das ist so lustig, weil man da so einen Einblick in so eine Welt bekommt. Also Jenny Nicholson, Halloween-Kostüms, und dieses Spaghetti-Kostüm, Ich lag auf dem Boden. Es ist so lustig, weil man da einen Einblick in so eine Welt bekommt. Also Jenny Nicholson, Halloween, Kostüms,
dieses Spaghetti-Kostüm,
ich lag auf dem Boden, es ist so lustig.
Ich habe auch noch eine Empfehlung,
die ich unglaublich lustig finde.
Die Tochter von Larry David
heisst Cassie David
und die ist unter anderem mit
Pete Davidson zusammen,
einer der jungen Leute von SNL,
den wir auch cool finden, der macht auch coole Stand-Ups. So ein bisschen der Stefan Tietze von SNL, kann man sagen. Der tätowiert ist, der cool ist, der Basketball spielt. Also eine coole Version von mir. Wenn ich bei SNL wäre, Amerika leben würde. Crazy Story hat, sein Vater ist auch bei 9-11 gestorben, also der hat auch, das verwandert er auch in seinem Stand-Up. Und erst mit Cassie David, der Tochter von Larry David zusammen, was ich schon lustig finde. Daher kenne ich sie auch, weil das eine lustige Kombo ist einfach. Stell dir mal vor, dein Schwiegervater ist Larry David einfach. Wie unangenehm, aber auch ein bisschen. Und sie hat eine Webserie, die sie bei YouTube hochlädt. Weniger Budget als gute Arbeit. Also einfach tatsächlich eine Low-Key-Webserie, die so ein bisschen ist wie Curb. Alles im Internet hat weniger Budget als gute Arbeit. Das stimmt. Aber wo ist das Internet jetzt und wo ist gute Arbeit? Aber es ist wirklich so eine Curb-artige, es sind Larry-David-Gespräche, die sie führt. Aber in unserer Generation wo sie auf einer Party, wie sie mit Leuten spricht,
die gerade irgendwie ein Date haben auf der Party.
Also wirklich, es ist einfach die Tochter von Larry David,
nicht nur von ihm, sondern auch von der Kunstfigur Larry David.
Und es macht so Spaß, der zuzugucken.
Guckt euch an Cassie David.
Sehr gut, nutzt das Internet besser und schaut euch gute Sachen an.
Und hört nicht zum Scheiss hier.
Adam Neely, Mark Brown, Jenny Nicholson und Cassie David. Schreiben wir auch noch mal in die Videobeschreibung. Machen wir eh nicht. Machen wir eh nicht. Aber richtig gute Sachen, guckt euch die man an. Aber merkt man auch mittlerweile, die Leute gehen weg von Nicknames. Die nennen sich, wie sie heißen. Jenny Nicholson, der YouTube-Kanal heißt einfach Jenny Nicholson. Ja. Und nicht wie früher, wo man sich dann Al-Blali genannt hat oder sowas. Das geht wieder echt stark weg davon.
Ja, finde ich auch gut.
Aber es professionalisiert sich ja auch.
Also diese YouTuber sind ja auch dann Persönlichkeiten, die auch ausserhalb von YouTube Werbekampagnen machen.
Es sind Brands, es sind Leute, die mittlerweile die Grössten, die ja sind Unternehmen.
Wie war das?
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Ich habe das nicht verstanden, was du gesagt hast.
Die sind Unternehmen, wie meinst du das?
Im steuerlichen Sinn jetzt? Die werden vermarktet wie Unternehmen. Wie ein Scheißsteuer? Wie meinst du das? Ich hab gerade rumgebullshitted, okay? Ich hab gedacht, man hört mich eh nicht, weil du gerade laut sprichst. Man wollte so tun, als ob ich gerade auch einen guten, interessanten Punkt mache. Man wollte im Hintergrund ein bisschen rumbrabbeln. Und dann ist es aufgeflogen, mein Bluff. Nein, die werden schon vermarktet. Grosse Influencer sind ja die neuen, die werden krass vermarktet. Das sind neue Produkte quasi. Wie warst du eigentlich dein Nickname? Wie warst du früher in Foren unterwegs? Wie hieß du bei Quake oder was immer du ballerst? Bei Knudels war ich damals, als Spy94. Spy? Das steht noch nicht in der Puffopedia. Doch, doch. Echt? Spy 94. Wo ich heute drin war in der Puffopedia, weil jemand ein Foto von meinem ... Ist das noch die Piraten-Folge eigentlich oder ... Piraten? Also, was gibt's noch über ... Piraten? Ähm ... Die haben Holzbeine, ähm ... Piraten, Ungeheuer, Kraken, der Kraken, Säbel, Degen. Piraten, Säbel hatten die, ne? Unter anderem, ja. Hatten die Degen? Kann gut sein. Haben die gefechtet? Haben die gefechtet oder eher ...? Ich glaube, eher gesäbelt. Da wurde eher gesäbelt. Ich glaube, es ist ein Dead End. Ich glaube ... Diese Tiefseefische, gab es ja nicht irgendeine grosse Entdeckung jetzt, dass sie so ein Tiefsee, so ein Wurm, der irgendwas konnte, was andere nicht konnten.
So ein Tiefsee-Wurm. Wo ich mir auch mal denke, was heißt Tiefsee?
Weil, ich meine ...
Oh, ich glaube mehr als zehn Meter.
Aber ganz sorry, jetzt mal eine Meinung.
Ist nicht das Meer primär der Meeresboden? Wer ist das, was die Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt dann auch mal zehn Meter nach oben, aber die leben nicht einfach mitten im Wasser, sondern am Meeresboden. Doch, natürlich. Die brauchen noch Sachen, um zu leben. Oder an der Oberfläche halt. An der Oberfläche, wo Plankton und Algen rumwirren. Ja, aber wo schlafen die denn? Ja, die schweben rum. Glaubst du, die gehen unter? Wie glaubst du, die müssen nicht die ganze Zeit schwimmen, um zu schlafen. Die haben eine Blase in sich drin, die sich mit Sauerstoff aufbläst und damit die Höhe bestimmen. Glaubst du, die müssen die ganze Zeit paddeln, um oben zu bleiben? Nein, aber die legen sie auch mal hin. Ja, und dann treiben sie halt rum. So diese Clown, ich stelle mir jeden Fisch so wie so ein Nemo-Clown-Fisch vor, der halt in seiner Anemone lebt. Und andere Fische werden es ähnlich machen, weil es ist ein gutes Konzept. Es gibt wirklich Fische, die ihr Leben lang weder die Oberfläche noch den Boden sehen. Na, das bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Sondern immer in der Mitte havern. Ich glaube, Oberfläche hat da, wo Nahrung ist. Ich glaube, Oberfläche ist schon ein Ding, wo oft Nahrung ist. Und Plankton und so ein Kram. Ich glaube nicht, dass die dann immer untergehen. Weil ich verstehe das immer nicht, wenn es heißt, okay, Tiefsee, oh, wir konnten jetzt mit unserem neuen U-Boot noch hundert Meter tiefer gehen und haben einen neuen Fisch entdeckt. What? Wo Florentin auch vom Läppchen besitzt und sagt, ist das doch nötig? Was reicht jetzt nicht auch schön langsam? Haben genug gesehen. Dieser neue Fisch, der ist jetzt wirklich, der geht nie höher und nie tiefer. Was ist der Fisch, sorry, ganz kurz, was ist der Fisch mit dieser Lampe vorne dran? Das ist Quatsch. Ist das nicht der beste Fisch aller Zeiten? Ist das ein Mythos? Ich habe Bilder gesehen.
Das sah echt aus.
Das ist ein Fisch, der hat so eine Lampe vor.
Aber es ist nicht anstrengend.
Und vor allem, du willst doch, es strahlt ja auch mehr in die Augen.
Es blendet doch auch massiv.
Aber kann der die ausmachen?
Also wirklich, das ist eine ernst gemeinte Frage.
Kann man das ausmachen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Weil ein Glühwürmchen kann doch an und ausmachen.
Nein.
Nein? Kann ein Glühwürmchen einfach sagen, aus. Ja, ich dachte so halt wie Luft anhalten, so und dann geht's aus, aber es hält nicht lange aus. Dann geht's wieder an. Wenn es sich verstecken muss, ist doch mega dumm. Genau wie der Schneebär, der seine Nase zuhalten muss, der Depp, kann der nicht einfach eine... Ja, aber dieser Fisch mit der Lampe, das fand ich immer schon faszinierend, weil zum einen ist ihm Dunkelheit so wichtig, dass er so weit unten lebt und ist Teil seines Lebens. Auf der anderen Seite hat er aber gesagt, nee, was will er denn anleuchten? Wohin will er denn leuchten? Was will er denn sehen? Er ist wirklich Kilometer, das ist ja ein Tiefseefisch. Was will er denn ganz unten sehen, dass er eine Lampe braucht? Ja, vor allem, warum brauchen alle anderen Fische keine Lampe? Das stört mich an Evolution. Wissen wir nur nicht, dass sie eine Lampe haben. Wenn es für einen Fisch gut ist, eine Lampe zu haben, warum haben nicht alle Fische eine Lampe? Ich glaube, die Idee ist, dass er damit andere Fische anlockt. Weil der heißt ja Anglerfisch, was erstmal pervers ist, ein Fisch Anglerfisch zu nennen. Nach einem grössten Feind des Fisches, nach dem Angler, das ist wie wenn du irgendwie eine Giraffe, Jägergiraffe nennst oder Wilderergiraffe oder so, halt der grösste Feind. Funktioniert nicht in meiner Sicht. Anglerfisch ist mega herablassend. Ja, ist wie so ein Chicken-Nugget-Hähnchen. Das ist falsch. Ja, Tiefseefische sind schon interessant. Manche können auch einfach, glaube ich, anhalten, also einfach die Zeit anhalten für sich selber und leben dann einfach nicht, sind dann tot, aber die können dann auch einfach sagen, jup, jetzt lebe ich wieder. Also die können sich quasi einschläfern und dann auf Kommando wieder sagen, jo. Aber wer sagt dann jo? Ja, das Gehirn. Und dann frage ich mich auch genau, wenn das Gehirn ja schon klinisch tot war, wer hat dann entschieden, wieder zu leben? Ja, das ist wie beim Urknall. Wenn vor dem Urknall nichts war, wer hat dann entschieden, wann es losgeht? So, ich erkläre es dir noch einmal. Ah nein. Dann ist es auch gut. Infinite Monkeys. Stell dir Infinite Monkeys vor, ganz viele, du hast auch keine Zeit, stell dir eine nie endende Anzahl von Affen vor, die an einem PC sitzen und tippen. Dann gibt es einen Affen, der auf dem ersten Versuch Shakespeare schreibt. Richtig, genau. Also ist der Zeit keine Rolle. Richtig, aber die Unendlichkeit der Affen steht ja sinnbildlich für die Unendlichkeit der Zeit vor dem Urknall. Heißt, davor passiert nichts, irgendwann hat jemand sofort, also davor ist nichts, weil sofort unendlich viel Zeit davor war und deswegen sofort der Umknall entsteht. Und alle anderen Dinge, die passieren. Also ist unendlich viel Zeit gleich gar keine Zeit. Gleich unendlich viele Affen. Gleich gar keine Zeit. Gleich kein Affe. Aber gab's nicht vor dem Umknall gar keine Zeit erst mal? Ja. Also unendlich viel Zeit. Ja. Das ergibt sogar Sinn. Ja. Gut, Stefan. Danke. Hat mir gefallen. Nee, das war ein kleiner Impulser-Effekt. Das finde ich gut. Wollen wir ein paar organisatorische Sachen abhaken? Gerne. Vielen Dank für die vielen Leute, die sofort auf Kaufen geklickt haben, als wir unsere Tour veröffentlicht haben. Vielen, vielen Dank, das ist mehr cool. Wir sind gespannt. Wir sind gespannt. Und auch an der Stelle noch mal ein lieb gemeinter,
durchaus netter Rat. Kaufen geklickt haben, als wir unsere Tour veröffentlicht haben. Vielen, vielen Dank, das ist mir cool. Ja, Tour ist ausverkauft.
Tour ist ausverkauft.
Und auch an der Stelle nochmal ein lieb gemeinter, durchaus netter Rat, ihr müsst uns nicht anschreiben, ob es noch Karten gibt, es gibt keine Karten mehr. Wenn auf der Seite steht ausverkauft, gibt es keine Karten mehr. Wir haben rückblickend, glaube ich, mehr Leute traurig gemacht als glücklich damit. Ja, aber das macht man immer. Ja, ich finde es aber auch ganz gut, weil man hat das Gefühl, also man kann Leute, also ich habe das Gefühl, man haben die Leute besonders glücklich gemacht, die Karten haben, und ich hab auch das Gefühl, angenommen, man macht mal irgendwann noch mal Shows, dann macht man die Leute auch noch glücklich. Was heißt Glück? Ist denn Glück wirklich die Befriedigung ... Was ist Glück? Oh mein Gott! Was war das denn? Haui, ich stehe dich auf den Tisch gehauen, so doll, dass irgendwo was runtergefallen ist. Ist denn Glück wirklich die Befriedigung eines Wunsches oder nicht vielmehr die Erzeugung eines Wunsches? Oh mein Gott! Gut, das ist eine gute Folge. Wir machen Fortschritte. Aber auch da nochmal, ihr müsst uns wirklich nicht anschreiben, ob wir noch Karten haben, weil es gibt keine Karten mehr. Wir machen das nicht so, dass wir sagen, hey, wir verkaufen 100 und behalten 100 zurück für Leute, die nicht fragen. Mir gefällt, wir verknappen künstlich den Markt. Das gibt wirklich ja interessant, also es gibt interessante wirtschaftliche Aspekte. Du eilst voran. Ich wollte nur wieder einen Impulsreferat halten. Du schießt entlang. Die haben gerade erst verstanden, was der Urknall ist. Nächste Woche erkläre ich dann, was künstlich den Markt zu verknappen heißt. Und die Ersten haben auch unsere T-Shirts gekauft, unsere neuen heissen Mer, zweieinhalb Jahre musste ihr unter minderwertigem Merch leiden, jetzt gibt's neue Merch und viele haben auch schon was gekauft und schon Bilder gepostet, sieht super aus, es gibt Probleme mit den Grössen, glaube ich, aber da guckt, wie gesagt, wenn ihr ein T-Shirt kauft und es passt euch nicht, kauft neues und daran könnt ihr euch hocharbeiten, wenn es ein grosses kauft ein kleineres, wenn es ein kle kleines, ein grösseres. Das ist dieses System. Und genau, bald gibt's auch Hoodies. Exklusiv-Info, megageil, bald gibt's Hoodies. Totaler Sellout jetzt einfach. Kauft die Beutel, es sind noch nicht so viele Beutel weggegangen. Wir lassen uns melken komplett. Ja, ja, ist ja richtig kromm. Was soll's. War Star Wars sowieso der Acht eigentlich die Szene, mit dieser Kuli gemolken wird, war das eine Metapher für das Star Wars Franchise wird gemolken? Franchise wird gemolken. Ja, vor allem dann sagt, Luke sagt ja so auch, ja, sorry, sein Blick sagt ja sowas wie, ja, was soll ich machen? Ich gehöre halt mit dazu, ich muss es halt jetzt machen. Vor allem Luke sagt das... Und Ray sagt so, äh, muss es wirklich gemolken werden? Oder bin ich nicht der Beweis dafür, dass es doch eine neue Geschichte ist? Ja, aber gut, Luke sagt, das ist das Einzige, woran ich überleben kann. Diese Milch ist das Einzige, woran ich mich ernähren kann. Woran Mark Hamill sich eigentlich selber gespielt hat. Es ist ja auch eine Metapher, die im Film wieder aufgegriffen hat. Das Alte gilt es zu überwinden. Und das Alte ist die ekelhafte Milch, die man immer ... Lass los! Du hältst immer noch fest! Ja, eben. Und deswegen, die Milch ist stellvertretend für das Alte, das überkommen werden muss im Film, was der Film dann leider nicht einlöst. Aber das Konzept ist gut. Das Konzept ist gut. Ich finde die Diskussion, muss ein Film immer Fragen beantworten oder reicht es sich auch mal interessant, Fragen zu stellen? Aber nein, ich finde nur, dass der Film nicht das Thema von Neuanfang die ganze Zeit bespielen kann, wenn er strukturell und von der Narrative her exakt das selbe macht wie immer. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss noch ein bisschen mehr über Star Wars reden. Nein, dafür hast du deinen eigenen Podcast. Ich sollte noch mal meine Meinung zu Star Wars Episode VIII irgendwo sagen. Schau noch mal bei Kino Plus zu sein, brich während der Sendung rein und sag, sorry, ich wollte noch mal eine Kleinekeit sagen, die Fans haben Unrecht, ich hab Recht. Ja. Das ist auch interessant. Meinungen zu filmen ist interessant. Da hat sich auch viel getan. Weil man mittlerweile im Internet, wo es so viele Meinungen gibt und so viele Leute, die man mag oder nicht mag, die man einfach kennt, die sich hinstellen und die Meinung sagen zum Film. Mittlerweile geht es darum, dass man sich in dieser Flut aus Meinungen den sucht, der die gleiche Meinung hat. Es geht nicht mehr darum, jemanden unterhaltsam zu finden, wo man eine neue Perspektive will, wo man versucht irgendwie, ah, so habe ich den Film noch nicht gesehen, wo man zumindest mal versucht, sein Hobby-Zoll ein bisschen zu erweitern oder zumindest eine Alternativmeinung mit der seinigen im Kopf konkurrieren zu lassen. Nee, man sucht sich sich mittlerweile den, der die gleiche Meinung hat und schreibt drunter, ja genau so, du hast recht, du hast den Weihlauf im Kopf getroffen. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass immer mehr entsteht, dass durch einer starken Meinung man das Gefühl hat, man würde sich auch gut mit der Thematik auskennen. Also was ich oft höre bei Star Wars zum Beispiel, sind Aussagen wie, der Film wäre besser gewesen, wenn Person X gestorben wäre, Person X nicht gestorben wäre, egal was.
Aber das impliziert ja, dass dieser Kritiker mehr Ahnung von Storytelling hat und die besseren Entscheidungen treffen würde als der Regisseur. Vor allem bei Filmkategien geht es nicht darum, sich mit Filmen auszukennen, es geht auch nicht darum, einen Film schreiben zu können, besser machen zu können, es geht einfach darum, Filmkategie eine neue Form, ist eine Form der Unterhaltung, ist eine Form der Perspektiven und was helfen soll, eine Kunstform noch anders wahrzunehmen. Und es ist vor allem Unterhaltung. Leset euch mal, da gibt es doch diese tollen Text von Lessing, oder nicht, der über Filmkritik gesprochen hat, Theaterkritik und Kritik, nicht Filmkritik, Entschuldigung, aber der über Kritik geschrieben hat, ich weiß nicht wie der heißt, aber so ein ganz berühmter Essay für ihn. Über die ästhetische Erziehung des Menschen? Ja, vielleicht war es das, vielleicht. Aber das ist typisch Deutschunterrichtmaterial, wo man mitbekommt, was Filmkritik eigentlich leisten soll. Total, aber ich finde es ist interessant, weil ich finde es ist ein essentiell komplett unterschiedlicher Vorgang, etwas zu konsumieren und etwas zu produzieren. Und es gibt viele Menschen, die von ihrer Fähigkeit zu konsumieren, die kennen sich wahnsinnig gut mit Star Wars aus, die kennen alles, die verstehen genau, wie der Film gemacht ist, aus einer Konsumentensicht und projizieren das darauf, dass sie auch gut produzieren könnten und dann durchaus sagen, wie es wäre besser gewesen, wenn, was einfach völlig falsch ist, was nicht stimmt. du viele filme anschaust hast du keine ahnung wie filme gemacht werden und der und hingegen man als filmkritiker aussagen kann ich bin der meinung wenn das so anders gewesen wäre hätte ich es besser gefunden hätte es mir besser ich weiß nicht du kannst sagen ich fand es nicht gut und ich fand es aus den gründen nicht gut aber zu sagen es wäre besser wäre besser gewesen, wenn das anders wäre. Ich hätte es besser gefunden, wenn es anders
gewesen wäre. Man weiß nicht, was
daran hängt, an dieser Entscheidung. Der
Filmmacher hat ja einen Grund, warum die Figur
stirbt. Und es hängt an ganz vielen anderen
Entscheidungen drin und das genau in die Narrative.
Und der Konsument, dem gefällt vielleicht
der eine Moment nicht, aber er versteht nicht,
dass vielleicht wegen dem Moment viele andere Momente
im Film total gut funktionieren, die er mag.
Aber er checkt nicht den Zusammenhang.
Es gibt auch sehr viele schlechte Filme, wo Aussagen diesbezüglich funktionieren, aber ich verstehe schon, was du meinst. Der normale Filmkritiker sollte das vielleicht vorsichtig sein. Wir waren mal ein Comedy-Podcast. Wir waren mal ein Piraten-Podcast. Wir waren mal ein Piraten-Podcast. Glaubst du, Piraten kommen mal? Was ist gerade in eigentlich? Superhelden sind so ein bisschen auf dem Abstieg. Bitcoin sind in. Jetzt gibt es nur noch Filme. Niemand macht mehr Filme, niemand macht mehr Musik. Alle machen auch. Ey, Dokumentationen sind in, habe ich das Gefühl. Dokumentationen sind die neuen Filme, fast schon. Bei Netflix sind so die ganzen Dokumentationen, die reinkommen. Und meine Prognose, Gespräche werden wieder in. Auf Netflix jetzt gestartet neue Serie
David Letterman im Gespräch mit
berühmten Menschen, Folge 1, Barack Obama.
Gute Folge. Komisch, dass es nur
eine Folge ist, weil man denkt sich, oh geil, da binge
ich jetzt fünf Folgen. Nein, eine Folge.
Das wäre eine Doku, dachte ich, wo er mit
Barack Obama spricht. Es hat auch was Dokumentarisches,
weil es ist immer so, man spricht über
ja, damals, als du über die Brücke gelaufen bist.
Schnitt zu, David Letterman steht auf der Brücke.
Und man nicht weiß, war der
Vielen Dank. Es hat auch was Dokumentarisches, weil es ist immer so, man spricht über, ja, damals, als du über die Brücke gelaufen bist, Schnitzu, David Letterman steht auf der Brücke und man nicht weiß, war der vor dem Gespräch bei der Brücke und die wollten das auf jeden Fall ansprechen oder ist er nach dem Gespräch zur Brücke gefahren? Oder steht er im Greenscreen und ist gar nicht wieder an der Brücke und die Brücke wurde nachträglich reingebaut. Aber da denke ich mir immer so, hm, komisch, aber toll. Und Gespräche, so Live-Podcasts gibt es viele, das ist in Amerika ganz groß, so auch Podcasts, wo irgendwie grosse, auch intellektuelle Podcasts viele Live-Podcasts machen. Ich glaube, das Gespräch kommt zurück als trendiges Unterhaltungs-Stift. Ich finde, sobald Gespräche nicht gestaged sind, habe ich verletztes Interesse an Gesprächen. Weil niemand muss sich Mühe geben in dem Gespräch, außer um unangenehme Momente zu verhindern. Wir müssen gerade verhindern, dass es unangenehm wird. Sobald wir schweigen, wird es unangenehm, also reden wir. Das ist mein einziger Beweggrund, warum ich auch den Mund aufmache mit Menschen. Deswegen einfach nach Hause gehen. Zu Hause ist es nicht unangenehm, wenn man schweigt. Wenn ihr Kollegen seid von anderen Menschen, wenn ihr arbeitet mit anderen Menschen, sprecht die auf dem Weg zur Arbeit nicht an.
Nein. Tut das nicht. Heute Morgen,
holy shit, ich sass im Zug, in der Bahn zur
Arbeit und jemand setzt sich zu mir
und ich gucke und ist ein
Arbeitskollege und ich,
dann habe ich ihn gefragt, hast du dich gerade
hingesetzt, weil du mich gesehen hast oder hast du
mich jetzt gerade erst gesehen und regst dich genauso auf,
dass du gerade neben mir sitzt, wie ich mich über dich und er so, ich habe hab dich gesehen und hab mich hingesetzt. Und dann hat er mir, okay, sorry, das fahr ich mich auch, dich zu sehen. Und dann hat er sein Handy rausgeholt und nicht mit mir geredet. Für den ganzen Weg zu Bahn. Und ich hab aber natürlich dann mein Kopfhörer rausgemacht und hab auch nicht mehr Musik gehört und so, weil ich halt diese Situation gerade als unangenehm empfand. Ich kann jetzt nicht einfach weiter weitermachen mit dem, was ich gemacht habe. Ich kann nicht wieder Musik hören, ich kann nicht wieder auf mein Handy schauen. Er schon, für ihn war das cool. Sprecht keine Leute an, sprecht nicht miteinander, vor allem nicht morgens, macht es einfach nicht. Kleiner, kleiner Tipp. Kleiner Tipp. Ich hab den Tipp aller Tipps, ganz kurz. Ich kann es nicht fassen, dass ich noch nicht raufgekommen bin, aber das ist der, also alle reden von Lifehacks und dann kommen sie mit so lustigen kleinen Ideen, wo man sagt, ja, mache ich jetzt, werde ich nie machen. Ne, macht man auch nicht. Was man machen sollte, ist Briefe kostenlos verschicken. Jeder von uns kann Briefe kostenlos verschicken. Schreibt einfach als Absender den Namen eures Empfängers hin und frankiert das Paket, den Brief nicht. Schmeißt einfach, weil Briefe werden dann zurückgeschickt zu dem Absender. Und wenn du in den Briefkasten einen Brief schiebst mit dem Absender des Empfängers, ich schreibe, Florentin will als Absender drauf. Muss der letztliche Empfänger dann nicht was zahlen? Nein! Es wird dann zurückgeschickt zum Absender. Also ich schreibe... Sollte, wir konnten den Brief nicht zustellen, aber dabei hat er den Brief zugestellt. Ja, aber der Empfänger muss mitspielen. Klar muss er mitspielen, kannst du mir vorher sagen. Aber ohne Scheiß, ich finde das echt... Also du schreibst als eigentliche Ad Adresse schreibst du irgendeine Fantasieadresse an, oder irgendeine, die es nicht gibt, oder irgendwas, und als Absender schickst du die eigentliche Empfängeradresse. Ja, du kannst einfach die Adressen tauschen und einschieben, ohne Briefmarke, und es kommt an. Getestet für euch. Ja, wenn du die Adressen tauscht, dann kriegst du den Brief selbst. Ihr dürft nicht den Fehler machen, den Briefmarken draufzumachen. Das ist die Idee des Tricks. Ja. Es funktioniert. Wie viel Geld hast du dadurch schon gezahlt? Nee, ich habe gezahlt, weil ich halt viele Briefe, ich schicke neuerdings viele Briefe, was ich vorher nicht gemacht habe. Deswegen habe ich drauf gezahlt. 10, 15 Euro. Ich schicke jetzt Briefe ab, die ich sonst gar nicht erst geschrieben hätte. Und dadurch bezahlt dann doch mehr Geld, als ich eigentlich gespart habe. Ey, das ist ja brandheiß. Bist du nicht der Erste, der... Ich weiß es nicht, ich habe es auch noch nicht gegoogelt. Ich finde, das ist die genialste Idee der Zeiten. Ich sollte jetzt aufhören, irgendwas anderes zu machen. Vor allem, ich habe gerade mit einem Kollegen gesprochen, und der hat irgendeinen Bekannten in den USA. Und der ist unglaublich reich, hat ein Riesenvermögen, weil er eine Sache in seinem Leben gemacht hat. Er hat sich die Seite stamps.com gesichert, briefmarken.de, halt in Amerika. Und irgendwann hat ihm die Postal Service, US Post, hat ihm gesagt, du kriegst 20 Millionen Dollar. Ja, Aber da frage ich mich immer, woher weißt du, dass 20 Millionen genug sind? Weil angenommen, jemand kommt und sagt 20 Millionen und du sagst, ja, und diese Trottel, wir hätten dir auch 200 gegeben, aber du hast schon über 20 Jahre gesagt. Und wirst du dann, bist du dann glücklich mit deinen 20 Millionen? Ich glaube doch. Wahrscheinlich schon. Ja, natürlich. Ich meine, es gibt einen Punkt, als ich meine, wenn es nur 20.000 gewinnt. Und du denkst, wie, ich hätte auch 20 Millionen. Dann ärgerst du dich den Rest des Lebens und kannst deine 20.000 nicht gewinnen. Du hast aber bei 20 Millionen so eine gewisse Grenze überschritten. Das stimmt. Es gibt einen Punkt, wo es wirklich egal ist. Ja, genau. Aber das ist schon interessant. Vor allem, ich hab immer gedacht in meinem Leben, ich hab immer mit dieser kruden Theorie drum gelaufen, dass ich dachte, alle Menschen sind irgendwie gleichglücklich. Die, die reich sind, haben halt einen hohen Lebensstandard. Um den zu erhalten, müssen die Risiken eingehen und haben Druck von außen, haben Angst, das Geld zu verlieren, haben andere Probleme. Aber dann gibt es einfach solche Beispiele, wo ich mir denke, der hat nichts dafür getan, auch seit einmal diese Idee gehabt und hat dann das beste Leben aller Zeiten. Krass. Genau wie das beste Leben aller Zeiten haben auch Musiker in Bands, die nichts dafür tun müssen.
In jeder Band gibt es einen Genie, der die Songs schreibt und der auch dafür verantwortlich gemacht wird, wenn das nächste Album nicht gut läuft, der natürlich auch das ganze Lob bekommt. Aber da ist immer einer der Bassist zum Beispiel, der keine Ahnung von nichts hat, der nicht mal gut Bass spielen kann, der ist einfach dabei, er war befreundet mit dem oder ist der Cousin des Genies. Aber es ist immer einer in der Band, der noch nie einen Song geschrieben hat,
der okay Bass spielt, aber dann auf den Konzerten trotzdem alle Groupies abkommt und halt auch den Großteil des Geldes mitnimmt.
Wer war das bei Binky Zagpou? Wer war das Genie?
Du warst das Genie?
Nee, ich war nicht das Genie, ich war der, der profitiert hat vom Genie der anderen.
Ich habe nächste Woche noch eine Podcast-Empfehlung.
Nächste Woche? Darauf könnt ihr euch freuen. Nächste Woche? Ja, nächste Woche. Wir sind durch, wir sind durch. Und nächste Woche haust du so eine Podcast-Empfehlung aus? Nächste Woche hau ich eine Podcast-Empfehlung aus. Freunde, passt auf, da kommt was auch wieder zu. Bis dahin, wir haben einiges empfohlen, ihr könnt jetzt gerne weitermachen, ihr müsst nicht weiter Podcasts hören, schaut euch tolle Sachen auf YouTube an, ansonsten wünschen wir euch eine fantastische Woche, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, schaut mal. Ich wünsche euch vielleicht keine fantastische Woche. Schaut mal bei Love Your Artist vorbei, da könnt ihr tolle T-Shirts kaufen und
ansonsten noch viel Merch, falls ihr... Auch wenn die Seite relativ unnommensichtlich ist. Ich hab's nur
gefunden, wenn man loveyourartist.de slash das Podcast so vor eingibt. Ja, naja, alles klar.
Macht's gut, schöne Woche, ciao! Heben ab, macht's gut, ciao!